franchement jamais y arriver mais
comment je vais faire c'est pas possible
oh là là au bon je suis tellement
fatiguée et les nuits fatigué fatigué
qu'est ce qui lui arrive au musée puis
saisi mais qu'est ce que çà et là c'est
moi c'est françois en braconnant
françois ou que sais je n'en peux plus
je suis épuisée que julie z avance oui
je suis mal et c'est un tel travail ne
jamais y arriver et didot si tu es
fatigué avant d'avoir commencé
c'est plutôt de la paresse as tu crois
moi j'en suis sûr et regarde tu vois je
dois je dois prendre se jouer le porter
aucune offre sérieuse pour venir prendre
celui là le dr kirk est revenue celui ci
s'est d'ailleurs pas pour le quatrième
trimestre après après apprendre la
brosse et le chiffon voici venir houston
et la haye et acheter les quais a poussé
reporter la brosse et l'autre sens en
effet prendre le sourd pour le supporter
leçon aux stores pas dire je n'y
arriverai jamais mais au fait que
casimir c'est pas difficile pourtant tu
sais j'ai compté le nombre d'allers et
venues entre les stands et le kiosque
moi il ya son fait non mais 13 13 mais
ça porte malheur nominaux sont très
superstitieux mais tu pouvais faire le
même travail on simplement trois voyages
3,3 voyage pas un de plus
impossible c'est pas bon signe il faut
être un génie pour faire une session en
ce moment je suis pas génial un trou qui
l'a inventé on y va ou alors en garde
attention du ponceau tu prends les
quatre juges se croient ils encore trois
heures jusqu'au stand du centre
j'ai deux
eca dupont la broche tu l'aimés donc
saut pour rien aux cordes du prochain
font du broc ce plastique un petit coup
de brosse turenne sur un chiffon dessous
du seuil du retour nos stands en stands
débat du bois 3 yards 3 pas une plus
parfait tu vois c'est sépare compliqué
d'après sera pas trop fait on on
annoncerait par atelier surtout que tu
as fait tout mon travail
merci françois
[Musique]